cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com in this video that's going
tremendously viral you know
all right let me just play for you guys
said he's going to oh my god really oh
my gosh you know oh it's devastating
oh don't do it please don't do it oh no
oh no yeah
I got I gotta be honest while I see a
lot of people on the right sharing this
video being shocked that fetterman had
this reaction to it that's going to work
a really really well for the leftist
base for the leftist populists they're
going to look at that as that the reason
why they like fetterman and they
obviously Democrats don't want his his
uh his stroke right his his uh his
Affliction or who knows what yeah I mean
right right and but but they also want
to downplay that they want to they want
to play up don't acute don't attack
someone who's suffering a medical issue
and things like that but the reason they
like the guy is that they're trying to
be like Trump they know that Trump is
reaching out to these middle American
working class Union guys that see that
that like more of what he does I'll put
it this way if you're a dude hanging out
at a hang out by the grill with your
buddies in the backyard having a beer
you're closer to Trump I know it sounds
shocking than you are Joe Biden Joe
Biden is so far removed with his
Rehoboth Beach Delaware upbringing and
whatever he was doing I don't know
riding horses and singing at the pool
having kids stroke his legs Donald Trump
while born rich and and wealthy and all
that is closer I'm not saying he's close
but he's closer to to a dude who would
hang out and have a beer with you they
need fetterman and they need this kind
of behavior that comes off as as like
more down to earth well and you just saw
Trump at the Iowa football game Iowa for
Cyrus State I mean he was like he fit
right in it was like he was the
grandfather of The Godfather of the
fraternity I mean well done steak with
ketchup yeah I mean he held the burger
up for everybody to see but you know
let's be clear why that resonates with
democrats for the same reason when
Donald Trump hoist a hamburger in the
air or says that he wants to have a
retribution to her that resonates with
his voters that behavior from fetterman
resonates with Democrat voters you can
you can show a Democrat all the videos
of Joe Biden literally grabbing children
on C-Span grabbing their crotches
stroking their hair yeah that's your
response you show that to a Democrat oh
no no dude when we when we have liberal
voters in here and actually you guys
have seen the video of the pot there's a
radio host asking the journalist about
Hunter Biden and the and the uh uh
corruption the journalist is like I
don't know you're talking about he's
like Hunter Biden said my dad takes my
salary and he goes I don't know about
that it's like that was uh Phillip
Phillip yeah the Washington Post Yeah
that's supposed to be someone that's
serious walks off the set yes so when we
have these people on liberal voters and
they come on rarely and they make it
like how come you won't have us on Tim
I'm like bro y'all are always invited
you just don't show up when I when I
pull up an article and I'm like here's
an article that says Hunter Biden
contacted DC to get prosecutor fired
they go that's a conspiracy theory
Washington Post no I'm like this is this
is the New York Times here here's the
New York Times saying Merit Garland was
pressured by the White House to
prosecute Donald Trump specifically
because Joe Biden told his staff he
wanted it done and they're like that's a
conspiracy here's the text here's the
email sometimes literally you have his
laptop I have his text do I do I I don't
have the New York Times propaganda works
oh here we go very well if the New York
Times pulled up the New York Times Jesus
darling faces growing pressure as
January 6 investigation widens hey you
don't like the New York Times I'm not
the biggest fan either but they outright
say in this let me uh is this one right
here here we go the Attorney General's
deliberative approach blah blah has come
to frustrate Democrat allies of the
White House and at times Biden himself
as recently as late last year Biden
confided to his inner circle that he
believed Trump was a threat to democracy
and should be prosecuted according to
two people familiar with the comment it
goes on to say that Joe Biden has
privately said he wanted Garland to act
less like a ponderous judge and more
like a prosecutor who was willing to
take decisive action over the events of
January 6. so when you have Joe Biden
saying to his staff I want Trump
prosecuted why won't Merrick Garland be
more decisive you think Merrick Garland
doesn't get to get the message so when
we're talking about who should be
impeached if if your argument is to me
and this is what they say they come on
the show and they're like Donald Trump
was digging up Turner's political
opponent and I'm like Joe Biden ordered
the prosecution of his political
opponent that's a conspiracy theory no
it's in the New York Times doesn't
matter they don't care well you had the
one lady from New York who ran her
campaign on I'm gonna get Donald Trump
that was her entire campaign and she got
elected and then uh I I don't know what
I think she she was the one that ended
up indicting him out of New York her
campaign was elect me all indict Trump
wasn't funny what else to say the same
thing
Leticia James yeah that's the one yeah
but look the left gets away with this
James came after us at Infowars and Alex
Jones too yeah that's right that's New
York yeah how defamation or something
look I don't know if I'm I don't know if
I'm at Liberty to discuss this but let's
just say Leticia James did everything
she could to try to hurt Alex Jones in
Infowars of course that's crazy man but
look the left gets away with this
because number one they control
everything now Long March through the
institutions over many decades and
number two they've got the protection of
the press so when you have the
protection of the press you can
literally get away with anything
including murder I agree but I think
we're winning and I think you look at
the the math and the economics of the
matter you look at Target they're stock
dropping Bud Light dropping you look at
uh uh Disney and Netflix losing
subscribers you look at uh sound of
Freedom Richmond North or Richmond you
look at even Yingling getting support
any anyone other than Bud Light those
those numbers mean more uh uh than and
those are hard numbers you just talked
about a new beer that's about to come
out oh no this is that already we have
some conservative dads Ultra right beer
Seth weathers and that's good apparel
because people want to support something
that isn't Global you know globalist
corporate propaganda right you have uh
apparently now they're they're shipping
them by by the truckload by Massive
semisfold they're they're selling so
much of this beer and uh I mean
everyone's launching their own thing
when Aunt Jemima gets pulled from the
brand Terence Williams says screw that
and he makes a replacement and I I what
it's one of the coolest things ever they
removed Aunt Jemima from the pancake
things and it is one of the most
shockingly offensive things ever to me
that they were like oh you can't have a
black woman on on a pancake box and I'm
like what why like the most popular
pancakes of all time of all time get rid
of her so Terence Williams has I'm gonna
put my face on the box then and I'll and
and I'll say that I say okay I'm gonna
buy from him regretted I don't need a
lot of Pancakes you know too much sugar
right I cut that out but we have a bunch
of cousin tees right now and
it's it's these woke companies need to
be told and they're told simply by not
buying their products so while we can
look at the political stuff that's going
on I think what they're doing to you
Owen I think we're doing the j6ers I
think what they're doing to Trump shows
how panicked and desperate they are New
Mexico shows how panicked and desperate
they are they have been trying to ban
guns for how long but if you look at the
list of states that are going
constitutional carry more than half the
country I think we're like 26 or 27
States now so what is the panicked and
desperate Democrat Governor do decree I
hereby decree and what happens people
walk outside with their guns say nope
it's not working so what what are they
going to do well when a person is
drowning they thrash about violently and
as they start to lose power which is
clear from 2016. Hillary Clinton wasn't
supposed to lose the fact that she did
show is the establishment power is
waning these corrupt establishment
shells inherited a machine they did not
know how to operate and they are losing
control of it and the people are
starting to take control back they're
freaking out because of it and they're
gonna get it's gonna get nasty but in
the end I think we win and that's why I
keep telling everybody people say the
stuff like you know they're talking
about what do we do now to resist I'm
like it's really really simple you knock
on doors you get the word out you only
buy products from companies that support
your values and you vote for Donald
Trump in 2020. and think about how
politicians and even people in the
political realm operate right it's all
about votes or popularity and so when
the New Mexico Governor comes out and
makes maybe the most anti-second
Amendment decision or decree of all time
what happens far left Democrat Ted Liu
has to disavow it David Hall the most
anti-second Amendment activists out
there has to disavow it so even they
know like hey we better not get go along
with this because this is not popular
right now it's it's I everything we're
seeing is acts of desperation but I
wanna I wanna clarify because people
keep saying like how could they have
control of the institutions but we be
winning because let's say that they have
70 percent of institutional power and in
six months they'll have
67 that means we are winning they are
being pushed back and pushed out of
these institutions for too long most
people have set back set by and let them
do these things and even during the you
know the uh I don't say the peak but
even in the in the trenches of the
culture war in say 2018-19 with Trump
and russiagate people were not doing
these boycotts or boycotts and in fact I
was kind of like I don't know it seems
weird to me I don't want to be like that
now we're at the point where we're
creating our own chocolate well daily
wire has their own chocolate brand and
it's got better ingredients the the
daily Jeremy's chocolate has like four
ingredients that no preservative garbage
it's like cocoa cocoa butter sugar and
milk or something isn't that part of the
populist movement too it's not just a
political thing it's even a health thing
yeah you know there's there's seed oil
to it seed oils all this other stuff but
you know here's an interesting
phenomenon that has been happening
really I would say Post Obama more than
anything maybe it's liberals being
anti-war to being pro-war but even
that's a little more nuanced here's
here's something that's direct and right
in your face
it used to be that the First Amendment
and the Second Amendment were huge
liberal causes liberals were always
going to go to bat for the First
Amendment liberals were always going to
go to bat for the Second Amendment where
that's not a liberal belief anymore now
if you want to be a modern day American
liberal Progressive Democrat your
anti-free speech your anti-second
amendment I mean that's that's been the
phenomenon that we've witnessed it's a
complete inversion right what we've seen
over the last like two decades since a
complete inversion because what you're
describing Owen is Classical liberalism
small L liberalism right what we have
now is a wholesale takeover of the
Democratic Party by the marxists by the
Communists and they call themselves
Progressive because they call themselves
progressives because it's a it's it's a
subversive ideology sorry which is
another inverse because they're really
regressing exactly that's exactly right
and I have always said that communism
Never Dies it just gets rebranded yeah
so what you have now is a rebranding of
Communism to make it sound sort of 21st
century and and hip and something that's
going to attract younger voters Etc and
it has been working but Tim to your
point you know conservatives for a long
time were anti-boycott oh we can't do it
because they'll do it to us and we're
better than that and all of that moral
superiority nonsense right but now we're
starting to feel our own power because
so many of us realize we're at a Tipping
Point and there is no alternative other
than losing our country so we're willing
to put our disposable income where it
counts and it's all organic it's not
like the left you know doing their their
you know astroturfing nonsense wait you
mean they don't actually like Dylan
Mulvaney come on but it's actually
organic right so so what we've seen with
Disney with Target with a whole range of
companies now has been an organic Choice
by millions of us to say we're going to
put our money our mouth is now and we're
going to make a proactive choice this is
a point that I've made a couple times
and I completely agree with you with it
there is an inherent vulnerability in
liberalism and that's that liberals
listen to their opponents and or their
their they believe that open dialogue is
important you believe in the first
amendment that means you have to hear
the opponents out people that you're
arguing with people on the left
people that are not liberals they do not
have the desire file you mean like
classical and philosophical liberal yes
when I'm talking about liberals I'm
talking about classical liberals when
I'm talking about people that they don't
agree with when I talk about
progressives I'm talking about people
that don't have an Enlightenment uh
doesn't don't have any respect for the
enlightenment they don't believe that
you can actually come to an agreement
based on truth and honesty they believe
that that it's all about perspective and
and so it all boils down to power and
you have to have you have to have
liberals understand that when you're
dealing with people that don't respect
things like honesty that don't respect
uh the the freedom of speech because
they don't believe that there is a
freedom they don't believe that there is
a truth so if these people are
approaching it without a respect for
honesty and and open dialogue and stuff
They're all playing a power game I think
that the classical liberals in the US
have finally started to realize that
that inherent vulnerability is there and
so you can be liberal with other
liberals and and approach other liberals
and expect an honest dialogue but you
have to first ascertain if they're
actually liberals if they're commies
they're God they're gonna lie to you
kami's always lie thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time